one thing that i noticed that uh i saw a
lot of athletes complaining about was
how bad the temperature is here oh yeah
and how bad the heat is it's absolutely
brutal poor people doing like triathlons
and stuff and like cross-country cycling
and like it looks great on tv you can't
even tell it looks hot like it just
looks like oh good weather yeah it's
it's disgusting here yeah i mean we
talked about this last week but the
summer here is [ __ ] it's insane and
just these poor athletes you have to do
like hour-long events in this heat all
right all right right now where we are
it is 34 degrees but because of the
humidity it feels like 41 degrees insane
it didn't it do be like that like even
just walking from the train station to
the office like it's a nice like brisk
five ten minute walk i'm [ __ ] dying
by the time i get it i don't care where
you live or what [ __ ] temperature it
is no one should be doing sports in 41
[ __ ] celsius no i should be doing a
triathlon
i don't care if you were raised in the
[ __ ] magma crust of this earth i know
there's gonna be one comment who's like
oh it's 50 right [ __ ] off yeah you're
not doing a triathlon on a 50 degree
light oh my god
yeah i'm wondering like how the [ __ ] are
they doing this or how how is like
anyone meant to compete in this weather
i wonder why i'm pretty sure i read
something i could be totally totally
wrong on this one that apparently they
did try and ask uh japan did try and
tell them like hey we should do it in
like september or something yeah the ioc
was like nope no we're doing it in july
and of all the sports that are like
perfect for this heat aka the swimming
is done indoors
yeah point
at least do that outside you know if i
feel good for the athletes
yeah jesus i feel i feel bad now i
didn't even think about that they must
be absolutely dying out there in the
heat dude it's brutal
yeah yeah but like i mean how how how
much is left of the olympics now that we
are i don't know not only what days left
where are we because it's been like it's
only like a two-week event isn't that
yeah we're on like
what yeah yeah [ __ ] or like day 12 or
something i thought it was like i
thought it was like a couple of months
no it has to be done it's like i think
one of the rules in the contract with
the olympics committed to the local
government is that it needs to be done
within like two weeks oh wow and no
longer no less like it has to
why does it feel like every olympics it
lasts so much longer than that i think
because it's just so stacked because you
get so like the hype for it is built up
more than any e3 event tenfold yeah yeah
yeah yeah any gay any no man's sky
wishes that it had this much hype like
because everything in in like you know
i've we've lived in japan for like two
years now right and since day one since
you've been here you've been seeing
tokyo 2020 stuff everywhere like
it's it's insane like everything is
tokyo 2020 like you can get a chocolate
bar tokyo 2020s on it for some reason i
don't know why why is this on here we
did actually buy uh some tokyo 2020
merchandise just because like oh let's
think about it right like it's one of
the few if not the only olympics that
has ever had you know been in this like
weird world situation where it's been
delayed by you yeah right and it's like
it's so like telling of it's like i
think aki bought a tokyo 2020 face mask
like that 50 years from now is going to
be a great story to tell
because it's like you know just to say
that like yeah we lived through a time
where there was such like an insane wall
pandemic that we literally had to a
cancel the olympics for a year but b
everyone had to [ __ ] wear this for
two years i mean it's it's weird right
because i feel like this olympics the
hype just like you talked about the hype
but i just haven't felt the hype at all
because i think i think last year
before covid hit it was the hype was
definitely oh yeah oh yeah yeah it was
definitely but like i think the moment
covered hit and it got pushed back a
year is when and then the hype for cove
had happened yeah and then i think
pretty much the german people just
turned against the olympics and they
were like we don't want it anymore yeah
even though japan is doing exceedingly
well this olympics as well it's great
it's good oh yeah they've won a lot of
gold gold medals already yeah they're
third right now i think oh [ __ ] okay
yeah they're doing very well see i i
just haven't been following them along
as much as i used to just because
i don't know just it like the high like
i said the hype just doesn't feel there
obviously in japan because
not japanese people don't want it to
happen for obvious reasons yeah but also
like internationally it just feels like
there's been a lot less
talk about it as well you see like the
odd article you see the audio it's been
a rough year i think i think yeah also
like political situations are getting
rough and you're seeing it in the
olympics yeah it's been it's been in a
lot of talks just not for the right
reasons yeah it just feels like
you know at least like
olympics pre i don't know like 2012 2016
maybe not 2016. i don't know didn't feel
as like [ __ ] like politically as well
yeah i think there's a lot of politics
in it now and that always was maybe i
was just younger and i didn't realize
but it just yeah it feels uh very tense
yeah yeah i mean the world is you know
in a tense state right now in general so
it definitely just doesn't help
everyone's just on edge now yeah i mean
like it's it's you know everyone loves
the idea of the olympics just like
the every nation gets together and we
just play a bunch of sports differences
to size and put our differences yeah put
our differences in size and uh play some
games friendly competitions um and you
know in any other olympics i feel like
that is the case in this olympics it
just feels like
nobody really like everyone's just
forgotten to care because everyone's
just like can we just have the world
open back up yeah like i see the empty
seats there it's it's reminding me that
it's still a depressing situation in the
world well most of the world at least so
i don't know it's it's it's been
difficult yeah definitely definitely
just wanted to be how has how has
who has been winning the olympics i have
not been keeping that at all china's
winning right now well it's always china
and usa at the top right yeah yeah and
then japan and then i think australia
and britain are like neck and neck yeah
for like fourth but i i it's hard to
tell what's going to happen yeah but i
mean china and usa normally always win
yeah they're usually the type and then
that's like the the cold war-esque thing
for them where it matters who wins that
yeah that's the friendly competition
unless
[Music]
15 volts let's go
uh roc republic
oh that's that's russia that's russia
roc is fifth grade region six oh okay
okay that's wrong yes britain isn't
doing too well this olympics oh i like
that commentator said man absolute
embarrassment for british foreign
absolutely absolutely
that was one of the events that britain
used to win at least somewhat
consistently yeah yeah i mean it's i
feel like it's it's
part of british culture
we actually have like a big deal about
yeah it's like rowing and cycling right
that we usually cycling would normally
have a really good tournament yeah
british people love [ __ ] cycling for
some reason like we invented football
and then everyone every nation just
beats us at football so we're like okay
we've got to find another sport i think
we invented do we invent quicker i don't
know if we might have pretty sure where
you're at i think you guys invented
qriket and rugby yeah and then australia
was like
well i saw that meme where it was like
britain invented sport gives it to other
country they become better and then
america's like invent a sport no one
plays it become number one
that's true